I've already told you that in a crisis, the
most vulnerable people.
Sometimes, yes, the most gullible people get
targeted by grifters and by scammers.
And the other thing we have to be careful
about during crises are basic rights being
either ignored or put aside or suspended.
Now, I'm not talking about something like
a stay at home order violating people's freedoms.
That's not what we're talking about here.
What I'm talking about are constitutional
rights that are part of our society, our government,
our culture.
That Donald Trump's Justice Department has
secretly asked Congress for the ability to
put aside specifically to detain arrested
people indefinitely.
And this would violate some of the most important
rights that we provide in the United States.
Politico has seen actual documents which show
the requests from the Justice Department at
as much as the virus itself is dystopian and
Trump's reaction to it has been dystopian.
What Donald Trump's attorney general, William
Barr, wants to do is also horrifying.
And the way that the request is worded, it
would allow chief judges of districts to pause
court proceedings, quote, Whenever the district
court is fully or partially closed by virtue
of any national disaster, natural disaster,
civil disobedience or other emergency situation.
What that means is that any rules or statutes
that apply.
So this means before an arrest has been made,
after an arrest has been made.
But before the trial, during a trial, after
a trial, all of that could be suspended.
And it goes to the heart of our constitutional
system and habeas corpus.
Habeas corpus is a writ that requires anyone
under arrest to be brought before a judge
or into court, especially to secure their
release unless there are wrong lawful grounds
for their detention.
So in the case of someone accused of a very
violent crime, there may be a decision made
that they are not eligible for bail, but they
should still be given that hearing where the
determination is made that entire infrastructure
is what the Trump Justice Department is looking
to have suspended.
At this point in time, and because it includes
pre-arrest, meaning before someone has been
arrested, it is particularly scary and dystopian.
It's anti-democratic.
Of course, it's the opposite of some of the
basic tenants of our system.
Now, to be super clear, this isn't about arguing
that courts just have to stay open in full
swing as shelter in place orders start as
stay at home orders start.
No matter how bad the pandemic gets, we're
not saying courts just need to stay open.
It's actually the opposite.
It's if you have to go in a direction where
courts can't operate or should not operate.
The leniency has to come to the people that
you'd be holding indefinitely without a trial,
not through the court.
Right.
In our system, the prosecution has to prove
guilt.
The justice system has to provide a speedy
trial.
You don't say, well, if they can't do that,
then the accused loses all their rights.
This is what we call a major red flag.
And if we give the president and the Justice
Department the ability to set aside constitutional
rights, we're not really a democracy.
I don't want to start naming dictators.
But look at history.
This type of thing, the arguably defensible
according to them.
Suspension of constitutional rights has been
a precursor to despots and dictators taking
it, taking power in history.
Trump already checks off many of the boxes,
questioning election integrity, even an election
that he won.
Lying uncontrollably, pitting groups against
each other.
Stacking courts, doing illegal things with
no repercussions.
Waging a war on the free press.
Lying about the violations he's committed.
Taking a national crisis and calling it a
war.
And they now want to get to suspend the rights
which are part of our system.
The virus is horrifying.
Trump's handling of the virus is just as horrifying.
And now this.
The Department of Justice doesn't need more
power and more and more leeway.
That's the last thing we need.
And it's weird that the small government conservatives
are very quiet on this issue.
I guess in this case, they're not so small
government after all.
One would hope that the Supreme Court would
push back against any suspension of the Constitution.
But we've got a pretty different Supreme Court
than we've had in a while.
Thanks to Donald Trump.
Just imagine if they get another right wing
justice on there to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
This is the stuff of nightmares.
We're fighting the nightmares
on many fronts
right now.